This is about Clark I'm here for the Brooklyn had a Black Berry Our street our stories project
we're here at the diner library and we're going to interview a couple of them are the diet you're saying
today right now we have Terry Miranda and it's every nineteenth two thousand and
sixteen where you boys.
I was born
at Methodist Hospital which was then Presbyterian Hospital
on six Street seventh Avenue in
Brooklyn and.
I think I moved as a infant with my parents to Connecticut because they have
a family father had brothers and then I was there about four or five years and came back to Brooklyn.
And lived with grandma and then Mary when my parents
split. On sixty eighth Street. He went to say
needs from
school
and been. In this neighborhood
in and environs pretty much all my
life off and on a few years here and
there and which neighborhood did you spend your. YOUNG
CHILD My young childhood was striker which was like but Eighth
Avenue the area Eighth Avenue for Hamilton Parkway.
And that's so neat from school and I guess it's considered indictor also
so that's where I spent.
My grammar school years went to school and had a business
school graduate as a
secretary worked in the city. Most of my life sometimes in
Brooklyn and segues into being a legal
secretary. So a lot of a lot of years were spent in
that
field and where your parents or my parents were from the Middle East.
My mother was from Damascus
Syria and my father was from the more Lebanon and
they're both Christian Christian Middle Easterners and they immigrated
here probably. In the nineteen teens in
the one nine hundred seventeen nineteen eighteen.
Something like
that when there was there was I think during the First World War around that
time and did they have other family here.
The whole families came with them. Yes my father's family was intact my mother and father
were alive.
My mother's family yes. My grandfather
came first and then calls for the fam the rest of the family they each had
seven brothers and sisters my from other side of my side.
So they're fairly large families on my mother's side. Several
of them died in their fifty's sixty's.
I think one of my aunts old in Brazil.
From Syria. One of her sisters. So I've made contact with all that family too
over the years we've
been in contact so it's it's nice.
I had thirty two first cousins at one point my life.
So it's been what are some of your earliest childhood memories.
Well I remember
that as children we played on the block. So we had a lot
of friends mostly school chums we all walked to school together and came
back together.
And my my grandmother's landlady was no we Jim so they weren't Catholic but they
were Christians. So they didn't go to the same church but they had her daughter lived
upstairs and she had three children and we were all friends you know we'd hang out or go to each
other's birthday parties. And where I live there was a
back area where all the garages were and they had little gardens. So we would play
in the backyard a lot and have the hose out in the
summer by the garages were
always after hours and. Playing stick ball and still
ball and whatever the games. You know games kids played at
that time. And there's always the parents of two out to watch over us. You
know. I have very pleasant memories.
I got my first bike when I was about
seven. And a bunch of us had bicycles and roller skates and one time
with old bike to Coney Island Believe it or not as youngsters.
I don't know how we made it. And
it was really it was really close knit and fun.
You know really knew the storekeepers the storekeepers knew
us the movie theater the Fort Wayne movie theater was raid
up the block from me.
So that was Saturday
matinees you know two features cartoons
news and a quarter. Nicolette I remember
so that was that was really nice. You know I had some.
Depression and Trammel off and on because parents
split but my dad was in and out of in and out of my life for a
while. For most of my life and he remarried and stayed in Connecticut after when
I was about twelve thirteen. But mom worked as a
seamstress as did most of the family on my mother's and my father's side to their role
in the garment industry cutters pressers
seamstresses one of my aunts on my father's side worked with
a wedding. Again designer. So she's to make samples
you know gorgeous I mean really good stuff. So we all learned how to sew a little
bit. It's not
tremendous as opposed to the children they can sew.
But Millen
now I'm trying their LADY
A No my mice just go to the factory after my mom after school which she looked she
worked in the
neighborhood and they used to teach me how to. You know belts or collars
or so pockets on stuff and stuff so is you know you learned
something good ice do my homework do a lot to.
Once we moved out of my grandma's house
and. You know to
this day the corner of sixty nine stream for Hamilton is almost the
same configuration was when I was a little girl had trolley tried at trial is
running that way for Hamilton on sixty nine a street down to fifth Avenue transfer
go downtown Brooklyn to see cousins and we should take
the
trolleys and I remember one neighbor two doors
down from the Italian family her grandfather owned a plot of land on
the corner
of sixty eight and a big plot of land. So the new
buildings but he had a big garden grapes and et
cetra grape arbor and vegetables and he used to have a wine distillery
in the back yard of those houses I told you
about and he is to make wine.
It was like you know it was really it was
really a stable childhood for me despite
the personal problems. I mean everyone was there for each
other you know and I used to hear.
My aunt everyone used to hear my aunt screaming for the Brooklyn Dodgers when the Summer
Games. To look up the blood and we didn't have
T.V. We didn't have T.V. then until I was
about twelve or thirteen I got my first
T.V. so very different
lifestyle but my aunt got a car and how my mom had a
car in single working women who were able to manage.
So that's that's my remembrances had cats used to get
killed on the trolley.
Tracks.
Torture and delicious to go at Thanksgiving.
We should dress up in old clothes and leaves to
go begging you know at the door so how they do and how we now Thanksgiving
was the day for that right I think it was just for money ways to go I don't remember.
I remember doing it you know dressing up and moms or aunts old
dresses. And going around with the
kids. Thanksgiving
Yeah I remember somebody else will remember. I don't know ask them about that.
But that's pretty much it.
Have you spent most of your adult
life in your oh yeah yeah book of Brooklyn. Yeah I've
never lived in other than Brooklyn that never lived any place else. I travel
I've traveled a lot when I was I didn't get married to later in life was about thirty
five and lived with my mom till I was
about twenty six and I moved to the heights as a
single as where I married him and married. As we've been married
forty one years.
Have two stepchildren and seven
grandchildren. So you know that's that's been interesting.
And when I was young I started
working at a high school it was like seventeen or eighteen I got my first full time job.
They saved my money and
travel you know go with a girlfriend remuda to Florida. You
know wherever and then when I was in my twenty's I went to Brazil to see
my cousins for the
first time my mom and my aunt had hooked up with them a couple
years before
that and then I traveled to specify kowtowing
to Europe. You know such
or went to Africa after I got married. He was raised
in Senegal.
Portuguese and so we went there for ten days I think it's
great it's a great experience France. He
has relatives and friends I had and Canada of course we have a lot of people around a
lot of the Lebanese moved to Canada too. Not a French because of the
French speaking
French
country at that time and what about this neighborhood.
Is unique.
What I enjoy and what I like is the diversity of
architecture and a variety of of supermarkets and
stores and foods that are
offered and now with the influx of the aura of the
Asian market Oh my God. I mean just fabulous stuff you
know and we have our own Brooklyn
Chinatown in the in the sixty's down all the
way. Which is growing by leaps and
bounds. And I enjoy that you know I enjoy
different cultures learning about different cultures being on a block that
has variety of people who live there Muslims Next Door Tarion.
We used to have no
wages. You
know variety of
people that live that live on one block is amazing.
And that's what I enjoy as well and it's very safe for children as far as I can
see them very few incidents
of abductions or attempted abductions or any kind of
violent crime.
It's really at a
minimum and if you read the police report it seems to be a lot
but it's never affected
us you know I mean I leave my door open all day
long and never had an incident. No one on the block as far as I know.
So you have some than dualism with cars and
things like
that cation
cops some drug drug stuff going
on goes on everywhere.
For
sure why are you part of that I can see
your I love singing. I've been singing since grammar
school in fact Seine from my grammar school right. Moved
out I got thirty five forty years later then move back into
the neighborhood started in the adult choir again there because I was in the children's choir and I
had sung at some other group and Manhattan too over the
years and then of a couple
or choir
had mentioned this about three years ago than three years
ago so I investigated and I love it I love singing and I love the
participation people a
great you know all ages and whatever we have a good time they'll say.
Well thank you so much for having Thank you. It was a pleasure talking with
you.